brothers and sisters has helped me on
this new project to sponsor 50
orphans brothers and sisters in
charlotte it's 600 pounds a year but i
wanted every one of you guys to get
involved by giving even if it's one
pound
please get involved now and shout out
and help us sponsor 50 orphans for an
entire year
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the qurani
app is about to show you your progress
with your soul
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
how are you doing all right yeah i'm
fine thanks what's your name over
marvin iver hi my name is ali um
i'm going to say a few words i want you
to tell me what comes to your mind yeah
um when i mention the word israel
what comes to your mind first i mean
dodgy state
why they just abused their power
don't know from what you guys have seen
what sort of things have you seen and
how has it made you feel i saw a fighter
on twitter i think it was two days ago
of a baby boy and he had like
not bullet shots but it was like the
plastic bullets
yeah it's really upsetting and i don't
understand why
no one was like
and there should be more awareness on
such a topic that's just shocking so
many
victims people using their platforms for
the wrong reasons
what has been happening to the
palestinian people for so long
yes yeah and what do you think
i mean and the fact that palestinian
people are standing up now that's what
makes the difference to me
is not saying they weren't standing up
before but
of course of course march and protest
and not be supported by the west is
wrong you know we need to those of us
who live here
should you know make the effort you know
at the very least to come out
and to show our support the false
conflation right between anti-semitism
on the one hand which everyone will
agree is abhorrent and
there's no place for it in modern
society and
anti-israel sentiment where you're
criticizing the government action which
we can do with any country in the world
so this kind of israeli exceptionalism
is in fact a racist concept in and of
itself because why is it that we don't
you know exactly yeah the thing is
imagine imagine i think this is exactly
tell me if i'm wrong here
imagine isis they're they're muslims
they're bad imagine isis says
that if anyone speaks out against us the
islamophobes can can you can you imagine
isis scene you you're islamophobic if
you talk about what we're doing
how would you stomach all i'm trying to
say well i'm demonstrating outside
have you guys ever heard of ill bit no
no no no not really so do you see did
you know that it was located here in the
uk
i didn't know that yeah i didn't know it
was bad in it
if i'm beating you up if i said that's a
clash don't get involved there's a big
problem
i think you'll call the police right
yeah okay what's the police don't do
nothing about it and they said oh you're
just crashing
that's wrong that's not fair yeah i
agree
i agree okay do you assess that maybe
social media has had an impact on the
mainstream media
yeah i would say so yeah yeah yeah
that's right i mean i think
people in general
so many many people you know look at the
horror of what's happening
and don't have a complication of knowing
which side to be on there on the side of
the oppressed
who having bombs scent and tanks sent
at them and guns pointed at them so
that's not complicated
so the mass media who are much more
interested in supporting the interests
of
the powerful have to listen sometimes a
bit
and so when they hear social media
saying
support palestinian rights they have to
give some space to that teach if i was
to ask you
guess what's the percentage of arms that
go from america
to israel what would you guess
wild guess 40 yeah yeah 40 40 yeah it's
70 percent
do you see it's mad it's mad didn't it
yeah yeah
um so i study uh masters in
post-colonial
uh studies in theory and we see
israel as a modern apartheid state and
um
we my uni goldsmiths gives money to fund
arms in
uh to give arms to israel so my course
have produced we've
sent a letter as of course to the
university to and we're
striking and not paying our tuition fees
to in protest against
some of the things that's extremely
commendable i think what you're doing is
you're acting as a student shield
in your university and obviously you're
a very intelligent and articulate person
hopefully we're able to put forward a
narrative okay
against this apartheid state against the
state that's it knows when it bombs the
most densely populated place in the
world
that there's going to be 80 to 90
percent casualties from civilians
and yet it continues to do so you know
yeah i think bella had to be very vocal
about it yeah she has yeah i've seen
that she has me
and i think it's so for like a young
girl that's very admiring that someone
who's such a big platform is using that
for good cause majority of them
don't use that at all so what's very
interesting is you know
uh israel they've got their own twitter
page as well so they posted that bella
hadid
has been anti-semitic because she's
speaking up did you hear that
oh i haven't heard that i did see that i
do think that
as a social media it must be so hard to
advocate your own
views when you're not actually sure on
the issue yourself that's how i feel i
don't know how to talk about such an
issue because
you don't want to say the wrong thing
you don't miss that you don't want to
say something that's gonna
insult somebody else but i do feel like
raising awareness upon
such a destructive issue it's just
important in itself
rather than being afraid of saying the
wrong thing or
something that's going to insult
somebody else you should just be
advocating something that's
what it should be so much more black and
white than it already is it's bright and
much wrong
do you remember this video have you seen
this video okay that video is of
um a jewish settler and design is
settler yeah
and he's basically going and stealing
the property of a muslim
and they're trying to stop him and he
uses this is what he says he says if i
don't steal it
someone else will steal it doesn't it
does that justify stealing it like
imagine if i came and said to you
i'm going to steal your bike if i don't
do it he's going to do it
do that justify it no no and i think
also that people are becoming a bit more
emboldened now
by in their labeling of the israeli
state as apartheid state
yeah um as a terrorist state even what
are your views on that
[Applause]
that is that it's correct to do so you
know it is
it's a state that um you know excludes
and
um and uh discriminates and wages war
against
um a people who live there
for hundreds of years if not longer you
know i do think things are changing i
think
that previously if you spoke up for
palestine as a mp
or in the media like you could lose your
job or like things like that and this is
a massive shift in the opinion and that
now it's sort of
it's okay to like stand proud and say
free palestine exactly that's how it
should be you know that
the fourth largest arms dealer to israel
fourth or fifth is the uk did you know
that yeah you did yeah
and did you know that the country that
gave legitimacy
to israel was the uk because of the
balfour declaration have you heard that
balfour
yeah i saw something about that you
heard that yeah
how old are you i'm 14. it's quite
impressive you know
like people are too scared to say the
wrong thing so they don't say anything
at all because
it gets pulled up a lot when people say
what you don't know because you come
from such a privileged background
you're not in that environment yourself
i think people just
instantly shut down about it and they
don't they don't want to say the wrong
thing but to be honest anyone that's an
advocate for such a
such a treacherous issue you can't
advocate the wrong
thing because if you're raising
awareness for something that's wrong
how can that go either way if i asked
you
or if you both got in a fight yeah okay
because this man it can be a bit
aggressive here
if you go into a fight and he's starting
to hit you yeah okay
um and if if you came and said can you
help me and i said well you guys are
just clashing
how would you feel i feel that was
unfair because it wasn't a fair fight
really imagine you went to the
authorities you go to the police and the
police comes and says what's wrong madam
and you're like this this man has been
punching my face and
you guys are crashing it's okay how
would you how would you guys feel i
feel uh taken advantage of yeah exactly
and that's exactly what's going because
if you look at if you look at what's
going on you've got little kids with
rocks
and you've got rockets are flying in and
blowing these kids into pieces
and always all the bbc's using is
there's clashes it's unfair i'm gonna
use some words and you tell me what
comes to your mind okay
and when i say israel what's the first
thing that comes to your mind flag
what's that flag flab okay uh the only
thing you remember israel
with what's happening in palestine yeah
that's what i meant that shouldn't be a
political thing
it's a thing for everyone everyone
that's walking down the street as
you've just like if it happened to me
like it's out of our control it's out
there
what are they supposed to do they can't
voice it all they can
pray on is that the media voice
and they haven't yeah and they have it i
mean
i've seen some pretty bad stuff i mean
like when i flick onto my instagram and
stuff like that
yeah you see like some of the things and
like all videos had to get censored and
things like that because like some of
the things that are happening are pretty
terrible
like the media representation has been
disgraceful it puts it as a fair battle
and it's not
it's bombing innocent civilians as you
said like i just think
even even some of the left media like
the independent and the guardian
and the bbc it's just not not covering
it at all fairly
your understanding of the reality why do
you think this
may be overlooked compared to other
issues
because i think it's more about like
where it's also happening because if it
happened here or something it'd be like
one of the biggest things that ever
happened
just because it's not here or if it's
not like in america or in a european
country
they're kind of overlooking it showing
us that you can't rely
taken down now and it's just like the
the people that disagree with your post
will never see them because that's how
the ai algorithms work so you can't
yeah you can't really rely on don't
worry we're going to smash that
algorithm